and give it up to your champion is very
friend we have a dual evolution
we teach our evo 2015 second seven Jim
doesn't say evil 2016 jdc our is our
evil 2017 champion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nice I step a little to show with the
punty so do it with the Hyperborea
that's it
Kringle toe that is your champion out
here
[Music]
you
[Music]
get up there another Korean monster
bursts on low-high walking up to the
stage
going up against oh me oh my so that is
like the fifth Asian international that
we've had right now that could possibly
get zombie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just outfit open syringe
[Music]
just a ring
[Music]
suppose even
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa hi very qualifies winner site top
eight his first ever evolution he's
topping
guys we are here it's another evil 2018
and we're here for the top eight of
Tekken 7 yeah so first on eSports low I
go it is the reigning second World Tour
champion I'm gonna need a break uy yuku
Don's there sitting on the other side
one of these two will move on
[Music]
[Music]
and you thought about they're getting
black hair all the help you've been a
nice
with all the damage your floor
the corner eased in a bad spot and he
Wiggles out of it in the thick foam and
that's the second time that you watch
but evil I hear great
the legendary Kareem
oh man he's what you really get anybody
able to close it out get it done the
great ones it sucks tying it up for the
piece I'd say the flaw oh my gosh is he
gonna get the wall punished final mix-up
oh my
oh he's gonna put up in the red yeah
this is gonna be the last opportunity
for our hero and by the end
classic mix upstairs
at the final round
it was a simple matter of crowd
[Music]
JDC are our against it one more he could
do it
oh my gosh
[Applause]
Paris I can't believe what I'm seeing
guys can I get a break any chance I know
we wanted to take a break later there's
any chance we could get a gurney
because the ad CR he got destroyed yeah
the name was a clobbering it was
unbelievable and everyone was so
deflated and he started home you know
how you can hear that the Thunder you
can hear it low high his first evil his
performance has been phenomenal up until
this point but Majin really is the fairy
tale story of the year and again I got a
reminder well this is gonna be a race to
three everything from here on out for
these players if they're able to win
they're only gonna be playing three out
of five don't forget it's not just two
out of three a little bit longer this
time I got the expand
all right so here comes all the way
Barry
he was ready for that slow too late man
yeah and there's always great last mix
up you go eight all the Japs oh my I
can't believe he's doing this on a
jacket killer Oh
[Music]
garnishes
[Music]
Oh
try to get a Juggalo
go for the ten string to tie it up
around all he gotta kill his wife to
complete his adding up look at the clock
oh and he gets it again it should be the
reverse Jack works it
yes Marcus very nice up oh the time I
can't believe it well oh yeah though the
lines don't count em out
don't try them out
oh my gosh see wet sided slide and slide
again you never know
or the exploder one-inch max cakes look
at the momentum oh oh he's going for the
counter capital punishment persistence
wearing it all the way down to zero
oh and here's a big puzzle let's go
those are huge damage combo therefore
margin corporate elbow tackle our staff
is out of here
but with the rain strikes coming and you
know it oh yeah he's gonna picture a
year Oh
and farthing stay alive that opportunity
here but a good Laura all these locals
are landing
and that's the earth big time
[Applause]
then losers bracket of Bali
[Music]
this is getting very nice did you see
that little timing it out of this
defense look Danny Jeff Juden incredible
training Oh
ad width and the kill it doesn't recover
in time huge miscalculation from Dan's
was a mile away and all he had to do was
step in and finish him off
his characters feel good right yeah but
I mean you know it's not not as dominant
as before it's the type of good way you
really respect the play
oh you have the type of good where
you're like oh he's just playing devil
did this yes I like this do it a bunch
of right dive kicks it's not it's not
like that this character is super good
but only on paper and that's why you
don't see a lot of Devil Jin's just
dominating Howard estate oh yes let's go
many people's favorite stage in the game
wanna find love that could be the start
of the head
oh not cold Oh Eastside coming he didn't
want you but he finishes the mob hey
that was a hard-working three Street
round but then Wow
[Music]
from all these do I'm still is that
gonna kill it my that might kill he has
a sliver lifeless basically it's the
first hit in the combo there look at the
clock this is gonna get fun ugly oh the
power lines God's look great for how to
bring oh oh my god interrupting the
stand step with an all-boy very nice
once again due to the bone is standing
from
yeah back hill normally happy all gasp
you see that private party breathless
Oh big Electra Oh drop it
what's he gonna do Paul oh my god you
drop it
he's staying on the ground this is
outrageous what a blow up any job and
very nice
this one got the water ready to roll he
just reset the bracket three one and now
both players are now in losers bracket
and it is one three out of five seven we
are about to see history right goal I'll
expand of kind of dejected yeah it does
doesn't he yeah she wasn't shaken he
definitely looks discouraged and there
is a you know as far as respect goes the
downpours mixing it up a lot 100
intercepted but it dropped it outrages
dropped there yeah this is the time for
you these things can't happen we said
Chavez loves deflated right yeah that's
not a good look
oh yeah this time he's kind of
questioning himself a steel ball Oh hit
but it is not gonna kill I don't think
it's gonna be very close Oh
[Music]
turn it up starting to change things up
oh yeah
Oh bully kick it to the sidewalk they're
gonna be enough it will very likely that
is the direction you
[Music]
chocolate
but no one has one down and that leads
to a free juggle the follow-up and great
adjustment there from low I able to get
the ball to fumble dilute Eliza Oh big
counter hit here's a follow-up
you might be able to get close to the
wall here
as I said it
that's why qualified
with opportunity and I look at mo I
wonder on the way from being evil
champion ok the low Oh
[Music]
it's your hair
[Music]
so first our good boys
second
[Music]
[Music]
you